demonstrations erupted in New York again
Monday night
the death of 30 year old Jordan Neely
Neely was homeless with a history of
mental illness Witnesses say Neely was
acting erratically on the subway last
week screaming about being hungry and
tired what are the club that's when
video lasting nearly three minutes shows
Marine veteran Daniel penny with Neely
and a Chokehold
as at least one onlooker warns it could
be fatal
Neely was pronounced dead at the
hospital his death ruled the homicide a
lawyer for the 24 year old says Daniel
never intended to harm Mr Neely and
could not have foreseen his untimely
death what would Justice look like for
the Neely family so Justice immediately
means an arrest
it means following the process through